[Music]
you know the jingle Nerys for
short-shorts spread this lotion on your
legs and hair disappears with a wipe no
shaving required so what's inside this
double busting stuff it starts with the
TAS iam thio glycolate this molecule
eats and of keratin the protein in your
hair that makes the strands weak it can
also make things stinky the sulfur in
there smells like a skunk see you so now
is loaded with a secret mix of
fragrances to cover up the stench once
the stinky stuff weakens here calcium
hydroxide delivers the final blow
it destroys strands of the root leaving
your legs silky smooth but those
ingredients can also be harsh on skin
that's where lanolin comes in this stuff
is what makes wool waterproof but here
the sheet grease replaces bats that were
stripped away along with your hair other
ingredients work just soften and soothe
your skin
- there's cetyl alcohol derived from
coconut and palm oil
patrolling finally there's aloe
barbadensis it's great for sunburns and
the chemical damage from the hair
hacking hydroxide yup the skin repair
agents officially outnumber their hair
removal ingredients but it's worth it to
skip the shaving things right right
feeling wired yet subscribe